you just have to write you just have to
QD there's I mean if yes you just have
to write that is if you want to be a
writer if you want to go into another
aspect of entertainment you do whatever
that is if you know if you want to be a
director direct you know or collaborate
with someone on something but if you
want to be me you just write you just
write you write you keep writing you
keep submitting you get better and
better at it there's no other there's no
other way at it and you keep pushing
ahead and eventually someone will read
your stuff it also about my other advice
would be for someone who wants to go
into this businesses don't do it if
there's anything else you can do and I
sincerely mean that if there's anything
else you can do don't do it because this
is really only a job for people who kind
of are stuck in it it seems exciting but
it's also it can be it's aggravating in
wearying and I don't I think you're
probably not very good at it we don't
get a lot of Renaissance men we get
people with who are very good at writing
and then have some interesting hobbies
but you know we're all a bit of idiot
savants like this is the one thing we're
good at so we just keep at it
because not just the not just the
aggregation of actually getting the
process a not just the aggravation of
the process not just the frustration of
get actually getting something made but
also the fact that so many people are
trying to do it you know you it the
competition is so fierce and you really
are one of a billion sperm you know
going at that egg that is a job and it's
it is just it's too competitive and
there I'm sure they're there I know
there are tons of very talented writers
out there and actors and singers and
everything else who won't get their
break you know who are having a tough
time their 20s and watching less
talented people rise above them and I
think if they keep pushing at it
eventually they'll find their niche it
might not be the one they wanted but but
it is it's a very frustrating career
path even even in successors frustration
just it's it's so hard it because of the
collaborative part of it it in because
of the the money and the effort that
goes into it it's so hard to get here's
my vision and actually get that made is
you know and unless you're Bill Gates
and you own your own studio it it's not
going to happen like you think it is
you know I I don't know quite the answer
to that I think I think merit is enough
if you keep pushing and pushing and
pushing you might not get the break you
wanted I think the breaks eventually
come and you know I think the largest
break you have is perseverance you know
if you have that quality eventually you
will break through but it is it can it
can be very rough especially now and
actually especially especially now in in
the field of comedy writing jobs are
drying up there's a you know less and
less scripted comedy out there right now
or scripted television in general you
know either businesses is in a bit of a
crisis and if you can be a lawyer and
ain't no you could be happy being a
lawyer be a lawyer please like I do
yourself a favor
it's cheaper to make reality shows which
are which are very entertaining and you
know it I think they're coming back
it everything's on a pendulum you know
you you can only entertain people with
the standard reality format so much and
people like stories they really do
people like sitcoms people like friends
so I think the pendulum is swinging back
and and and but it is it's tremendously
expensive to hire a staff of writers to
hire a bunch of actors and and a top
right crew and make something that looks
like it should be on television for
television it's really easy to get a
video camera and video takes someone
eating bugs